من مكاتبها الزجاجيه الهادئه في سان
بطرسبرج غربيه روسيا تدير شركه فاجنر احدى
اكبر الميليشيات المقاتله في اوكرانيا
تصر فاجنر على انها شركه عسكريه خاصه الا
انها جزء مهم وفعال من النسيج العسكري
الروسي
اشهر قليله من الحرب يظهر قائد فاجنر مع
بعض من جنوده صفقه بين رئيس الشركه اف
جيني بريكوجين وسجناء جنائيين روس القتال
في الجبهه الاماميه لسته اشهر مقابل العفو
والعوده للحياه الطبيعيه اكد يدير الرجل
المقرب من بوتين المجموعات المقاتله في
اوكرانيا ظهرت للمره الاولى في قتال عام
2014 قاتلت في سوريا وليبيا واماكن اخرى
لحمايه مناجم الذهب ضمن صفقات الروسيه مع
تلك الدول نفت روسيا وجود افاجنر في
اوكرانيا كما نفت اي صله بينهما يقول
مسؤولون بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتلي فاغنر
ارتفع من نحو الف الى ما يقرب من عشرين
الف مقاتل في اوكرانيا اي قرابه عشره في
المئه من اجمالي القوات الروسيه على الارض
برزت قدرات مقاتلي فاجنر في معارك
السوليدار باقليم دونيتسك في ظل انتكاسات
الميدانيه للجيش الروسي في الاشهر الاخيره
ظهر رئيس الشركه مع مقاتله في سوليدار ق
ان قوته سيطرت على المدينه الاستراتيجيه
تضرب روسيا عصفورين بحجر تنفذ المهام التي
توصف بالقذره في قتال المدن دون ان تتحمل
تكلفه الخسائر هذا الدور دفع الولايات
المتحده لتصنيف فاجنان منظمه اجراميه
دوليه رد مالكها برساله ساخره مواجهه
للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
يساله عن الجرائم التي ارتكبتها فاجنر
مقاتلون فاجنر ليسوا وحدهم الغرباء في
الحرب يقاتل الرئيس الشيشاني كذلك الى
جانب القوات الروسيه هناك يرسل رمضان
قديروف الاف المقاتلين من الشيشان الى
اوكرانيا هناك شيشانيون اخر ونقاتلون الى
جانب القوات الاوكرانيه خلاف شيشاني داخلي
يتحول الى صراع بين قدروف وكتائب الشيخ
منصور الشيشاني هكذا تستعين كل من روسيا
واوكرانيا بمقاتلين اجانب لحسم الصراع
ويستعين المقاتلون الاجانب بكل من روسيا
واوكرانيا لتحقيق مصالح اما السياسيه او
اقتصاديه كل ذلك في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا المستمره منذ عام